so generally we get engineering
proposals from the researchers which are
highly ambitious and having done enough
of these over the years we're kind of
able to identify which ones have the
highest chance of success and so this is
how we determine what we're going to
invest in and obviously there's an
opportunity of this is really going to
be a paradigm shift in terms of
effecting a new underserved population
new technology that creates new
experiences for Humanity that kind of
stuff you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using if you want
an inside look at how a research idea
goes from project to prototype to
product you should hang out with Gavin
Genki for a while he's the general
manager of engineering for MSR Redmond
where he created and runs the central
engineering group over the past two
decades he's overseen more than 700
software and hardware engineering
projects from internal MSR innovations
to Microsoft product group partnerships
today Gavin takes us on a guided tour of
the research engineering landscape and
the engineering pipeline recounting some
of central Engineering's greatest hits
he also explains how the lab determines
which projects get engineering resources
and reveals how one of his own projects
ended up in the Museum of Modern Art
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
davin Genki welcome to the podcast
thanks Gretchen for hosting me you're
the general manager and engineering
research manager of MSRs
Central engineering and because this
group is so different from the others
here at MSR I want to split this
situating into two parts so first give
us a really short elevator pitch for
what you do in Central engineering and
why your group exists right so a massage
core mission obviously is to advance the
state-of-the-art in computer science and
also deliver cutting-edge technology to
Microsoft itself and so our team
essentially is a capability for hire
within the division to help researchers
transform their ideas into reality and
it's both you know very early and also
late stage engineering engagement with
the research teams it spans tech
transfers internal research team
engineering from the first napkin
conversion of an algorithm into a living
breathing software or hardware so we
pretty much cover the spectrum and the
team that I have is fully
multidisciplinary with engineers program
managers designers Quality Assurance
folks and hardware engineers and the
challenge today compared to you know two
decades ago when MSR was first formed
when there was pretty much just the
beige box underneath the desk that was
the state of the art of computing at the
time the industry and the landscape has
dramatically shifted and to create
software and innovation is dramatically
broad so when researchers want to
innovate an army of one or two or three
sometimes just cannot achieve it so it
requires a deep bench of product
disciplines and also working style you
know diversity too and being able to
create these manifestations
so my team essentially is a central
capability for the Redmond lab itself to
tap upon when
the research teams don't have enough
people to do something ambitious or they
need specific skills that they can't
necessarily hire fall and so my team
fills those gaps and executes well now
that we know what Central engineering
does let's zoom in and talk in more
detail about the current engagement
model you've sort of alluded to that
just now maybe you could start by giving
us a snapshot of the traditional
engineering to product pipeline and then
explain this Central engineering model
and how it came about and how it's
different by design so historically
Microsoft Research when it started 25
years ago there were researchers and
what we call embedded research design
engineers and an R ste which is a
research software design engineer it's R
plus ste and at any moment in time those
embedded RS DS can be you know 100
percent are 100 percent ste and anything
in between and that slider changes over
time so that's traditionally how MSR was
structured up until about 20 years ago I
actually started out as an embedded rst
myself so I kind of got first-hand what
being an engineer in MSR was like in
that traditional model so about 20 years
ago Dan Ling the VP of MSR he wanted to
model a similar setup for MSI Asia had
where they didn't have embedded RS T's
but they had a centralized model a pool
of Engineers that their lab could draw
upon and what that kind of tried to
address is the elastic need that
research teams have in being able to
efficiently assign in engineering
resources to teams that needed a
specific capability for a small amount
of time or specific skill sets they
couldn't hire for so Dan Ling and Jack
breeze came to me and said we like to
form something here
can you set something up we'll give you
two heads to start with and come up with
an engagement model with a lab and see
exactly what happens so I did that I got
two slots for engineers and
obviously I was the third slot as a an
active engineer at the time - and so I
came up with this kind of RFP request
for proposal model where researchers
would submit kind of a single sheet of
paper saying what they wanted to achieve
and what they thought the scope was and
I would take those sheets and
essentially do kind of a value
proposition analysis of them and kind of
a technology fit to see if I had
engineers who could work on these things
and this is how the central engineering
model started let me ask you then what
was your metric for choosing a project
yeah so the proposals would come
directly to me and then myself and the
office of directors at the time we would
sit down and huddle and look over these
proposals and I would obviously I had
pre vetted them and had spoken of the
researchers to determine you know
exactly what was being requested here
and so I would get kind of a gut feel in
terms of yes this is ambitious yes this
is achievable no this can't be done
without ten engineers and a whole
product team behind it and I was kind of
applying an instinctual gut model
approach to these analysis of projects
as leadership change I kind of respected
my insights into these but they wanted
something more formalized so I tried to
reduce what was my instinct into an
actual formula so I try and equally
balance the tech transfer value
proposition is it going to advance the
state of the art for the researchers
themselves do we have a good engineering
fit with these kind of projects is it
achievable and then I kind of have my
own chip which would be the kind of the
fun factor metric so I broke this
equation into kind of five pieces with
our new leadership and we started
running the projects using this model
now today that has gone through
essentially seventeen years of evolution
we have a whole new process now which is
based on the existing models and
weightings and that kind of stuff and
it's called pitch tank so pitch tank I
came up with the cheesy name based on
love that named the show shark tank
right
you know we're by inventors would come
on the show to get VC funding and so
pitch tank was formed whereby we also
were trying to address kind of
transparency issues because researchers
didn't really understand how decisions
got made and so we really opened it up
in terms of the researchers would
actually do the pitching of their
proposals themselves rather than me
present to the office of directors or
leadership so very much like the show so
they own the messaging they own the
pitch in the presentation I also changed
who the program committee was in terms
of the evaluation and a leader Donald
Cosman currently wanted to completely
democratize and open that up where
leadership themselves wasn't involved at
all in making these decisions history it
was owned by the people of the lab
themselves and so I equally split up the
program committee into an equal
weighting of for researchers and for
engineering folks from my team so we
could bring the engineering perspective
to these decisions the researchers could
bring their research perspectives in
terms of evaluating these projects and
so we've run pitch tank for about three
years now we've had about five sessions
and it seems to be working really well
how many do you choose yes so per tank
so the pitch tank that we just ran two
weeks ago in January 2020 we had 16
pitches on the line which was our most
ever was actually challenged we had to
split this across three days of three
and a half hour sessions which is quite
the workload and there's a lot of due
diligence that we do ahead of time so
the researchers still have to write the
proposals and then we also have a pre
pitch session with the researchers to
help them home what their pitches are
and what their value proposition
requests are going to be so I have
members of my team help them hone that
and then after the pitch tank the
committee get together we have a scoring
session where we enter these value
weights into our scoring model and we
create a color heat map
which actually shows basically the
scores on a heat map how we execute and
prioritize which projects we're going to
invest in I am seeing a reality TV show
here yeah well let's talk about you for
a minute Gavin and what gets you up in
the morning you've been at Microsoft
research for a long time and at
Microsoft for even longer and you've
done a lot in your career here and your
current role though you're both a
partner level leader and what I would
call a roll-up-your-sleeves doer and
that's by choice so tell us how you keep
all the plates spinning above your head
and why yeah the plate spinning thing is
quite the challenge so what gets me up
in the morning is obviously meaningful
work both myself and the engineers in
our lab and obviously the researchers
too we find great meaning in the work
that we do when we're obviously
privileged to work with several hundred
PhDs with cutting-edge breakthrough
technology and ideas so for me and folks
on my team you know we get a vast
diversity in job content and to be able
to come to that every day and not only
work on new projects but new angles to
the problems that we work on every day
is just profound so for me as an
engineer obviously I lead a team and I
provide engineering leadership within
the lab to the researchers and beyond
but I also am an individual contributor
engineer myself I'm a trained engineer
by profession and I really strive to
keep that alive because I feel if I'm
not an effective engineer and up-to-date
and practice and versed in the latest
technologies and challenges and stuff
like that I don't feel like that I can
be an effective engineering leader and
be able to steer and help my team steer
the research execution in creating real
solvable engineering problems I have a
real issue with over-commitment because
when I see these incredible research
problems being presented I have a
problem not saying
but that over-commitment helps me really
focus on delivering and executing on
innovation and that's also a role model
for the rest of the team too because
they see that and kind of feel us in
diving into the hardest firmware
engineering problem or whatever it is so
I get the best of both worlds both in
terms of engineering leadership managing
an incredible team of talented people
but also staying a talented engineer
myself how do you keep your creds up
I'm just looking at hours in a day and
what you do here I know because I've had
people who work with you talk about you
when do you do this it's a challenge
obviously when I'm at work I do the
least amount of individual contributor
engineering but in my kind of role one
doesn't have a work week per se when you
find passion in a career it spills over
beyond a 40-hour week so I do find
precious time at the end of the day when
everyone's gone to bed to basically
innovate as an individual contributor
engineer I've even resorted to try and
avoid the commute by car which is pretty
horrendous from Seattle over to the east
side of a canyon so I actually have
started to cycle the work which is hard
my commute time and I can basically find
an extra hour 45 minutes an hour each
working day by wait wait so you get here
faster by riding your bike than by
driving in a car well the commute really
is bad
yes it's an e-bike so I do cow
it's still a good workout I thought you
were gonna say you rode the bus and then
did more innovating on the bus which
would be a good little you know TV show
as well well so I would actually get
more work done with the bus but I don't
find time to work out so I kind of get a
workout and save time come you know
there you go the productivity hacks
going on all the time
[Music]
Gavan your central engineering team has
worked on more than 700 projects over
the 20 years that you've been at this
and over such a large range of topics
that it would take less time to list
what you haven't done than what you have
so before we talk about some of your
more recent work give us a brief
overview of some of your past favorite
projects maybe in the form of central
engineering's greatest hits yeah so it's
really hard to pick a favorite child so
I'll do my best to take a good sampling
there so generally the ones that stick
out in mind have been kind of the roller
coaster rides where there's been intense
pressure and also big unknowns one is
their Kinect for Windows so this was
back in the day when the Xbox releases
skeletal tracker device for its gaming
console and so the hacker community
managed to hack that for general use
outside of the console before Microsoft
had oh dear a story there
and so the VP of the entertainment
advices group and the president of
research needed to come up with this
solution so I basically said well Gavin
what can you come up with in terms of
creating an SDK and runtime for Windows
which kind of fills that gap and so I
picked a few people in my team with
incredible skills in signal processing
and basically we talked for Xbox
skeletal tracking code and essentially
we took those algorithms filled in some
big gaps and sorry we created a full
runtime which included all of the audio
stack - and an SDK setup program samples
and that kind of stuff and the president
of research at the time says well we
need to release it by June so
essentially we had 14 weeks to deliver a
company grade offering for Kinect for
Windows so that really stuck out in my
mind it was a fantastic run they were
lots of you know hot collared moments
there some other ones that come to the
top of our list so Skype translator was
another great one this involved working
with the research team the machine
translation team and the Skype team in
terms of how do we create an experience
that links the machine translation back
end with the Skype front and so my team
provided the program management the user
interface engineering and all of the
quality assurance testing aspects to
that that was another kind of thrill
ride which involved I think five
different continents of players and we
work very closely the machine
translation team and we ship that and
it's interesting that the long tail of
research takes many years for technology
to appear in the mainstream and I recall
seeing in this Christmas 2019 Microsoft
commercial there was a young girl
speaking to a reindeer and the speech
translation aspect of Skype translator
was essentially behind that commercial
so it's incredible to see how long it
takes innovations in research to finally
get into the forefront and they have
reindeer now in the language selection
that's right I'm Klingon as well I
believe some other ones that we've done
so project premonition we worked with
the researcher to create the world's
most advanced mosquito trap which was
kind of a healthcare research endeavor
and so we created a hotel which had
special doors of entry into the hotel
rooms whereby we do wingbeat frequency
analysis of specific mosquito types so
that the mosquitoes could be trapped and
essentially their DNA be ground up and
tested for things like Zika virus and
stuff like that and so this was an
incredible engineering effort for the
hardware lab to engage upon yeah and
eventually I think several thousand of
these devices were made and deployed so
that was another fun one that comes to
mind another project which is of my own
creation called Microsoft tag and this
came from this
Baco technology that I had and this was
another kind of over-commitment
challenge pickle that I got myself into
where by myself and a marketer from the
Xbox team wanted to change the marketing
barcode industry consumer user
interaction with magazines and
billboards and that kind of stuff so I
had this color barcode technology which
worked really well with the cell phone
camera technology at the time when we're
talking the late-2000s here and
essentially we made a pitch to the
president and we got some brands such as
cereal manufacturers really excited and
essentially again I committed myself oh
I'm gonna create a product and we'll
launch it at Consumer Electronics Show
on five different mobile platforms with
a cloud back-end with marketing tools
for publishers to use and leverage and
monitor campaigns and so again with an
incredible set of committed people who
covered my behind with this we executed
and we delivered it and actually a
30-person product team got created
around this and the products actually
lasted for several years and I'm gonna
make a bold claim here that this is
probably one of the most pervasive
pieces of technology that Microsoft
might have ever deployed in that 15
billion color barcodes were printed and
a circulation eventually the product was
Sun downed as business strategy changed
and his license off to another company
but that was an incredible ride of my
own technological creation with the
color barcode and actually creating a
workable platform well it doesn't look
like the pace of central engineering is
slowed down a dollar is slowing down so
let's talk about what's happened just in
the last year and again it will take too
long to do the entire list of your year
Gavin but in the immortal words of Janet
Jackson what have you done for me lately
so the team's been working on again some
remarkable innovations with the
researchers so one of the projects that
come to mind is video AR so essentially
doing augmented reality but using
virtual reality displays
when this involved creating a new brand
of camera device that the hardware
engineering team created for us which
was very high resolution in order to not
give viewing sickness to people when
they're looking in our right motion so
she's okay and so this was a full stack
kind of endeavor both from electrical
schematics all the way up to pipeline
and software titles so that was an
incredible multi-year project that we've
been working on another one is the
third-generation elevator whereby we're
bringing ambient computing into the
everyday work environment we have an
elevator control system where you can
literally walk up to the elevator and it
can determine your intent to actually
press the button to go into it now and
so we actually do wait it can determine
that I'm going to push the button to go
up or down not which floor I'm going to
well we actually have two parts of this
so are these first deployment of this
was to actually determine intent based
on your walking pattern before you got
to the elevator in the second phase
which we rolled out last year
essentially puts an in-car experience
where by using RFID and speech you can
literally say I'd like to go to floor 4
or based on what's in your calendar it
knows that you're a meeting and floor
two it will automatically press the
thoughts my gosh that's also been a fun
engagement it's working with the
elevator companies and so a very
talented engineer my team has been the
architect for this and engineer I'm just
shaking my head and then some other
projects
I personally over committed myself to so
one was the firmware and software for
the project era of Parkinson's watch all
right so the research team kind of went
into different parts of the company but
we had a second-generation piece of
hardware and because I had familiarity
working with this chipset I did the
firmware and then also decided to help
write the clinician software so that
patients can actually use pens so they
can actually do analysis on
Tremmel responds to different vibrations
in this new prototype watch and so we're
now engaging with recess institutions in
the furthering this work let me
interject that high and young was on the
show and she does an entire sort of
overview of project Emma and how amazing
that was for this young woman who was an
artist Emma and she couldn't draw
anymore cuz her hand shook it's a
fantastic story so I just want to say
listeners can look that one up for more
detail on that I didn't know how much
involvement you had was it yeah that was
very meaningful work for me because I
aside from the the very fun technical
challenge obviously it's serving an
underserved community in terms of
improving their lives and so tying in to
that now I'm kind of generating a theme
to my kind of underlying passion so I
was working with the innovations team
about a year ago on detecting pollution
using inks that changed colour based on
different gas levels in the atmosphere
and I thought well perhaps there's also
a parallel way of doing this digitally
and so I came up with this harebrained
idea of creating an air quality sensing
device which could be cellular connected
doesn't require any infrastructure be on
a cellular signal so we could do dense
air quality measuring and so this kind
of hardware firmware innovation kind of
pulled in the other parts of the
research team and so there's a
significant effort around air quality
measuring that we're now actually
deploying to major US cities which give
new insights in the kind of pollution
and climate awareness so this has been
another incredible project one of the
hottest lines of machine learning
research across the labs is teaching
machines to make decisions under
uncertainty you've said that operating
under uncertain conditions is one of
central Engineering's greatest strengths
and even a differentiator so talk about
how your ability to work with ambiguity
plays out in your world so generally we
get engineering proposals from the
researchers
which are highly ambitious there's often
quite a bit of naivety around the final
mile execution of these things whereby
they have an algorithm that works great
on a huge desktop machine under their
desk but then they want it to run on a
chip that runs on 3.3 volts with a
battery life of 10 months or so so then
we have to refactor the research
prototype code into something that's
actually deployables
and so having done enough of these over
the years and I guess almost two decades
now we're kind of able to identify how
these things turn out and which ones
have the highest chance of success and
so based on this gut instinct you know
this is how we determine what we're
going to invest in and obviously there's
an opportunity of this is really going
to be a paradigm shift in terms of
affecting a new underserved population
new technology that creates new
experiences for Humanity that kind of
stuff right and so we kind of wait all
those things and we're able to boil down
you know where our investments are going
to be and what technology is most likely
to succeed you've alluded to a deep
bench in the conversation today and I
love sports analogies so what that means
to me is that you're researchers can
expect great things from your central
engineering team what kinds of people
are you working with here and your what
now 30 person team how do you get them
Scout them draft them and bring them on
the team so I've crafted my team over 17
years so essentially I've cherry-picked
many people over almost two decades and
generally the people are that have the
highest chances at success are those
that are deeply curious they have an
absolute love of learning they know how
to work in ambiguous situations they
aren't intimidated by what they don't
know and so I've also picked people with
a very broad range of backgrounds
they find true craftsmanship in their
work and pride in what they do and many
of these people have been since the
creation and founding of the team so now
these folks that I picked from the very
beginning of the team's creation but
also I've had some fantastic new
recruits over the last few years and
these folks are going to be the future
of the team they themselves are younger
they bring new perspectives in terms of
how to engage with technology how to
engineer technology so with the 30
people that I have many of us having
worked together for such a long period
of time you know we don't have to learn
how to work with each other we have 70
years of knowing how to execute in
ambiguity we have each other's backs
that kind of thing I'm also very proud
that my team is almost 50% women that's
awesome
so you talked about your high capacity
color barcode and I happen to know that
it actually made it all the way to the
Museum of Modern Art for some reason so
I want you to talk just a little bit
about how that ended up there and then
what are your thoughts about the
importance of beauty and art and design
and technology because I know this is
something a lot of your team members are
interested in so the barcode itself came
from a project working with researchers
that we were doing on trying to create a
counterfeit proof ID and so we're trying
to stuff a cryptographic hash of
birthdate and all that stuff together
with the person's image so that neither
could be faked and in order to achieve
that density the black and white barcode
of the day just wasn't achievable so
came up with the notion of using colors
to store additional bits per symbol and
essentially came up with this color
barcode and somehow it ended up being
picked up in some trade magazine that we
were trying to achieve this and the
Museum of Modern Art was doing
a initiative along the lines of design
and the elastic mind which is how
momentous changes in technology reflect
major adjustments in human behavior
right and so it got picked again a
museum and whatnot it was exhibited
there for several months and that's how
it ended up there all right and so you
know just in terms of I've seen a
picture of it and it is beautiful how
then do you think an employer deploy
concepts of beautiful design and art and
beauty into the work that you do so
actually I've always had a love for user
interfaces and when I first started
Microsoft I saw it as a user interface
engineer in the sequel group creating
the first graphical user interfaces for
the product and so I was experimenting
with kind of the first 3d looking user
interfaces for Windows that Microsoft
had released the buttons and things had
kind of beveled locks and stuff like
that so I've always had kind of interest
in design and by no means a designer I
just don't want to be designer but
because of that I've kind of been
attracted to projects as an IC which
have had that aspect to them I was
involved in the founding of studio 99
which was basically a design and
Technology and a technology and design
kind of initiative within MSR and so I
also kind of pick projects that have a
design element to them I don't think it
can be understated that user experience
and user interaction is a very under
lock discipline and I had an incredible
user experience manager working for me
over the years who really honed my
appreciation for that in kind of design
first engineering and innovation and so
that's containing it over the years
[Music]
we've reached the part of the podcast
where I ask all my guests what could
possibly go wrong and as we've discussed
already as an engineer I suspect a good
portion of your job is telling
researchers what could possibly go wrong
but you're in a research organization
and so inherently you're inclined and
maybe even mandated to take more risks
so aside from telling a starry-eyed
researcher it'll never work
what kinds of things do you see in the
current milieu of high-tech research
that concern you and what keeps you up
at night yeah so my role I guess is to
play the bad cop which is to often point
out assumptions that researchers might
have in taking a piece of technology to
the next level I'm not so much
intimidated by the technical challenges
my biggest concerns are the speed from
conception to delivery of an innovation
and the competitive challenges that we
as a company face and so this is both in
terms of potential team size to tackle a
specific innovation and also the breadth
of disciplines and skills that are
acquired that go into these things so
that's the funniest answer because it's
basically how can I execute what we got
to do that's the thing that keeps you up
at night in addition to your off hours
innovation which literally keeps you up
at night
it does actually falling asleep well
we've established at the Venn diagram of
your personal life your professional
life and your leisure life could
probably be represented by one circle
and that the three paths kind of form
one story give us a short history of
Gavin Janke where did it all begin
what Singh led to another how'd you end
up here so I guess my first experience
with computing when I was age 12 and I
requested a Sinclair spectrum which was
a z80 based actual for one of the first
color personal computers so I was lucky
to get that for Christmas and I started
tinkering with typing basic programs
from magazines and
Mike's first experiences with technology
then from age 7 until 17 I always wanted
to be a dentist
it wasn't until a cruel teacher said
Gavin you'll never make the grades to be
a dentist that I actually really ated
what I wanted to do and in hindsight I
think I made the right decision which is
I will continue their computing track
and a junior in high school
I was lucky to strongarm my parents into
outlaying
one of the first IBM clones that were
affordable with an EGA display and I
decided to pick turbo C as my mechanism
for creating software on that thing when
I was 17 I went on vacation with my
parents and we were waiting to get on a
cruise or something like that and we
went into a book shop and there's a
saying which is don't judge a book by
it's cover
I actually judged a book by its cover
and the book was programming Windows by
Charles Petzl and this is how my
intersection with Microsoft started and
I got the Microsoft compiler and I
started developing Windows apps kind of
before I got to college and in England
we have the degrees whereby you can take
a sandwich degree where by the third
year in college is actually on an
industrial placement so I wrote to
Microsoft in the UK saying do you know
of any companies that are using your
Windows development kit because I'd like
to do my co-op here with them and they
says well why don't you pop down and
we'll chat to you so I drove down to
Microsoft UK and chatted to their
developer support department and I left
loaded up with SDKs and os/2 development
SDKs in my arms and basically worked for
my third year industrial placement
Microsoft product support in the UK I
also created an internal scheduling and
phone book directory app for Windows and
that kind of got me notoriety within the
company
one of my mentors back at the time said
oh you should apply for an internship in
the development groups over in Redmond
so I was all starry-eyed at that and
actually managed to secure that this is
when I was introduced to the sequel team
and had an internship there and
essentially upon my exit they offered me
a full-time position so I had my hardest
year of my life which was finishing my
final year of university knowing that
I'd be working in the USA in the sequel
server team as an engineer so that's how
my start with Microsoft began and the
rest is kind of history
Devin tell us something we might not
know about you and how perhaps its
impacted your life and career yeah so
from about age 10 until 21 years old I
was a sprinter and my speciality as it
were was the 200 meters so I had a some
amazing but hard Scottish running
coaches where I was a member of the
local running club essentially it was a
year-long commitment what by I'd run in
driving sideways rain in the north of
England and over the years you know I
went to competitions and stuff like that
and by age 17 this culminated in me
winning the bronze at the English
national school championships and sadly
20 yards from the end I pull a hamstring
who knows how that ending might have
happened but I became part of the
English team unfortunately because of
that injury I wasn't able to compete but
by my Microsoft internships I couldn't
offer that kind of dedication to my
running so I obviously rededicated it to
Microsoft but I think that decade of
intense focus and dedication to that
gave me the focus skills and ability to
manage stress you know on the starting
pads in a National Stadium so I really
think that's helped me manage various
aspects of my career
I've got the music to Vangelis running
through my head you know running on the
beach in Scotland in the rain well we're
getting to the end of the podcast and
I'm disappointed because I want to keep
talking to you forever so maybe we'll go
for a pint do you do pints here I drink
a pint at the end of every podcast I ask
my guests to leave us with some words of
wisdom and you're talking mostly here to
an audience of researchers phd's
postdocs emerging researchers and the
people that love them from your position
at the intersection of what I would call
blue sky and rubber meets the road what
are our listeners to be thinking about
and working on if they want to follow in
your footsteps and what kind of journey
are they in for so I really feel that if
you can find a career where you can
combine your passions and your hobbies
into it that's where you're really gonna
have an incredible journey I don't think
one can confine oneself to a 40-hour
week to find incredible success and
richness in a career so I really feel
like for me risk-taking has been an
incredible part of what I've gotten out
of my career where one shouldn't feel
intimidated by one's own constraints and
fears and if you can find a way of being
able to overcome that I think you'll
really fame richness and meaning in your
work but also I feel like engaging
outside of one's specific job role is
also another important aspect for me
collaborating with others in hackathons
and stuff like that surprising things
have happened in my career whereby I've
learned a new aspect of engineering
which is set up subsequent years and
joys of future work yeah I'm seeing the
Venn diagram overlaps again it's like if
you can find what you love it almost
isn't work exactly
Gavin Genki thank you for joining us
today thanks so much for the pleasure
[Music]
to learn more about Gavin Genki and how
the central engineering team helps turn
research into reality visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]